[cheery string music]
♪ ♪
[tense string music builds]
- You're in my chair.
- Oh, my God, I'm so sorry.
I-I will leave.
- Sit back down.
- [relieved exhale]
- [groans]
What's your name again?
- Jake.
- Cake.
- Um--
- You wanna sit at
the big table, don't you, Cake?
- More than I've ever
wanted anything.
- Let me ask you a question.
Do you think
Santa Claus is happy?
- I'm pretty Jewish, so...
- I don't think Santa's happy.
I mean,
maybe he started out happy,
but he wanted to bring
joy to the world,
so he created Christmas.
But after he went down
enough chimneys,
he found out
not everyone likes Christmas,
that some people are
Jewish or Democrats,
or they think Christmas
shouldn't be about gifts.
So now Santa lives all alone
at the North Pole,
surrounded by elves and reindeer
he underpays and doesn't trust,
and he can't tell anymore
if Christmas is good or bad.
[sighs]
Trust me,
Santa Claus isn't happy.
You're better off being
a dirty fucking elf.
[solemn music]
Is that cat hair on your suit?
♪ ♪
- Yes.
- I love cats.
- Me, too.
- Now I'd like you to leave.
- Got it.
♪ ♪
- Jesus! Fuck! Sorry.
Uh, I've had a bit
of an emotional day.
- Oh, well, I understand.
Say, what have you got there?
- Oh, well, there's one person
in this office
who had a worst day than me,
and I thought this would
cheer them up.
- You--you mean me?
♪ ♪
[gasps]
A guitar.
But I don't play.
- Oh.
- Why would you do
such a nice thing for me?
- Because it's Remember Day?
- Thank you, Pat.
- Yeah, okay.
[cheery music]
♪♪
- No, you--you are such a good